quando avuto ultimamente che un ragazzo
che fa parodie animate ha fatto una
parodia su di me devo assolutamente
commentarla perché ho visto un secondo
di quella parodia un secondo e ho detto
wow
attenzione questa è una parodia nolo per
dire non è in realtà sappiamo che lo fai
perché skill fregene titolo porta
visuale ma è normale vabbè provare
anch'io stati lo faccio anch'io
va bene vediamo che cosa hai fatto vai
tutti se non merita mi piace solo entro
un pomodoro che dispiace che per terra
l'arte contemporanea può andare anche a
[ __ ] per quanto mi riguarda bella
tutti ragazzi io sono pari a si
fidanzino ragazzi perché no ai capelli
quelli con la marmotta morta perché il
mio vecchio taglio di capelli
e quei muscoli zio non li vedro neanche
tra duemila anni però apprezzo le
mutande con i cuoricini la presunta
guardate che cosa incredibile
l'ho detto perché nutella è anche una
lettera
vediamo chi la manda recaro pali sono
gene sono profane un regalo di piatti e
su quello che vi posso permettere sono
povero nei pressi c stasera sono malati
il mio gatto fuffi è stato mandato dal
nostro verdi marco breve dovrei parlare
mamma il cabrera netto cosa le farà quel
male dei ds piacerebbe vederti mangiare
la nutella che più ha regalato perché
questa sarà l'ultima volta che ti vedrò
con affetto che cosa cazzo sto guardando
lega barba bene mangerò queste nutella
per tadino solo un pochetto
ma non faccio l'obiettivo almeno
cucchiaino lo uso ma questo non è
nutella
[Musica]
per dovrebbe essere lei vi chiamiamo
all'adrano della finta che era nel bar
ma immagino
[Musica]
la madonna che lardo ne basta banca però
porca [ __ ] veda contesto molto a me
tutti stata fatta questi montino basta
basta basta dove dove dove mi piace
questo video ma io me lo trovo questo
animatore lo trovo col mio involtino
l'attaccante progetti dove si chiama
parigi parodia unboxing nate saluta
antonio e gianni morandi a perché ci
sono dentro il video speriamo che sta
roba
poi come è stato il papà la mamma degli
haters ha fatto a questi bottino maina
gioia dopo la modella senza olio di
palma a eccolo gianni voi dovete dire
che già immagina merda perché lo fa con
uno a tre ecco non è che viti di tanto
magari siete l'altro non è quella di
prima perché a schifo aprì lo ha
scaricato questo pacco tra spedito un
certo gino controtelai teheran detto
nelle mani di gianni e bellissima 10 ti
puoi prenderti animaletto alien sono
rendo però nel dubbio a qualcuno va bene
un anno sono molto gay portarti un
chiaro di quanto è brutto credo che
questo essere mi abbia insegnato
qualcosa
ma cosa
raga ma che a cd frank the belt
romaniche acini ti fai devo capire ma
qua quali a ct spiega manda linkra mason
di acidi che servono cracchi ecco ho
trovato nel pacco alla creatura di alien
temi ha in sé minato e vediamo perché
questo sta riuscendo
la lega e anche qui mentre vuoi puntare
di capriglio cover antonio giorno
archivistico va dall cascato dato parte
della sua forza per farlo grazie di
cuore papa ne ha ancora una bomba trovi
i busti giu ancora freschi ma chi mi ha
operato
sono stato io perfetto solo nell'aver la
signora buzzurri non sapevo tu fossi il
chirurgo infatti non lo sono
l'altro è finito nono libri non è finito
vi prego parigi fa vigeva be bel bello
globi tosi e vivo grazie a 0 89 che è
venuta a conoscenza della sua morte di
saab e stemmi aree talmente tanto dalla
felicità che non risveglio
ok ora sta bene non apre più pacchi
effettivamente per quel nome non ne ha
proprio gianni dovendo sottoporre a
interventi chirurgici facciali ne ha
approfittato per trasformare la sua
faccia in ciò che ha sempre desiderato
ora è così lottando ogni non c'è più ora
non dà finalmente libero grazie mail a
caldo senza motivo gino continua a
deterrà il cuore youtuber mentre il suo
vicino cinese continua trombati tua
madre a poveri niente bellissimo e stato
stupendo fede se chiara ferragni ora
ragazzi dovevo farla riesce un'asta rosa
perché non è non aveva senso è però sono
lusingato seriamente profondo del mio
cuore
i ragazzi computer e volevo dirvi una
cosa va tanto importante domani che
domenica farò una live quindi non uscirà
è previsto normalmente ma ci sono io in
live dalle 3 del pomeriggio in poi
quindi vi aspetto tutti quanti romani
live sul canale dei ragazzi se vi dovete
più posti un'attività era un po cosa
avrei voluto anch'io che l'apologia cose
un po più lunga perché la mia vita ora
non ha più senso però va bene e
soprattutto i punti di zuri al tower
reggono meglio di quanto pensassi cosa
dovete si vive un momento mi piace anche
marito jacques e comito transizione se
non dover finire che ci dividiamo
proseguito dei ragazzi
[Musica]
qui
no